mr. melih al hamdulillah assalamu
alaikum peace be unto you thank you for
tuning into the Deen show where we're
helping deliver the message of peace to
you into your home and if you're
watching now you're getting to sit with
some Muslims not just one today but we
got one two three four five of us oh my
god
five Muslims for these Muslims about
what are they thinking about what do
they talk about well we're letting you
in to our lives so if you are not yet
Muslim you don't know nothing about
Islam you were just tuning in don't go
nowhere we're gonna be talking about
some serious issues and for the Muslims
who are tuning in we know when we leave
this life all the money stays behind and
the family and what follows you to the
grave of those things stays back but
your actions what you did in this life
did you worship the crater not his
creation did you submit and surrender to
all the things that the Creator told us
to do did you just have fun dance party
and now you expect to get paid with
paradise no all the messengers came
taught and brought that same message and
they warned two people at the Hellfire
did you qualify to go to the Hellfire or
paradise so we know that one of the most
important things is to leave off so many
good actions one continuous charity that
you gave now people are benefiting from
knowledge you taught somebody how to
submit to God to someone's making Madhu
someone's praying someone's worshipping
the crater not his curse you gave him
dower and you're benefiting from that
without reducing anything from your good
deeds so you did so many good actions
and that follows you to the great and
then a righteous child making
supplicating for you so that opens up
the door for our topic today here on the
D Shore homeschool Islamic school public
school couldn't you send that child you
don't give them any kind of good
education and then what you just
bankrupt because then that child's not
making do I'm free for you when you
leave this life so we're gonna be right
back here in the D show
to discuss this very important top and
then let you be the judge at the end
we'll be right back peace
please be on to you assalamu alaikum
today he better get to him okay we're
gonna set up a little format his first
time we got crossfire you guys know
crossfire on the D show we got opposing
views some that are arguing or
presenting the case for Islamic school
for public school for pre-school no okay
so let's get it a short introduction so
we want to go ahead and pass the mic
around just start off with yourself
please introduce yourself briefly and
then just pass the mic around we'll come
back to myself what's your name and what
position are you arguing for
assalamualaikum wa rahamtullah Autocar -
my name is brother Yusuf Jabbar I've
been working with Islamic schools for
five years and on top of that I've been
dealing with the youth for twenty years
both Muslims and non Muslim and of
course I have to argue for the Islamic
schools
Manickam my name is Salim Patel I serve
as a commissioner on the board of
education in the city of Passaic in
addition to that specific role
we do home school my daughter and my
wife
at the same time teaches at an Islamic
school in this in the town that we live
in so I kind of touch all three
different areas and I'm not making an
argument but rather I'll speak to my
specific experiences and insights is to
what I feel are the strengths and
weaknesses of each of those methods
Somalia and other ethnic and Iran a
public school teacher a business
education teacher in Parsippany in New
Jersey I'm also a boys soccer coach FBLA
advisor of Future Business Leaders of
America and also as of this year became
the Muslim Student Association advisor
as well again like brother Salim said
not necessarily in my in favor of public
school but again I'll talk to my
experiences my daughter's do it and
Islamic private schools some which is
ugly so now I can't why everyone my name
is Shakeel whom are you by profession
I'm an entrepreneur and with this
discussion what's relative is that I'm
the founder and the CEO of Wall Spring
elementary a unique school model that we
recently opened up a couple of years ago
at how this Queens I'm going to be
inshallah sharing a lot about the
Wellsburg model itself I personally
don't like calling it Islamic schools I
like to call it a school we don't
usually say that I'm going to have my
Islamic burger and then put online my
islamic clothes and get my islamic phone
so I'll just call it a private it's a
private school I want to call it a
private school so tell us now so
consensus we got private school it's
everybody's on the same page masha'Allah
but look we have a lot of not yet Muslim
so look you know they catch this channel
and now they see for five Muslims on the
stage and they're like what are these
guys plotting now you know I'm planning
so before we get into the main topic
what do you I really like to just get
this off the minds of the people let
them know that because there might be a
Muslim friend and the guys like you know
called his his
non-muslim neighbor not yet Muslim
neighbor and he's sitting there through
this and and he's like come on come on
and when I were talking about this topic
but on the back of his mind he's
thinking you know al Qaeda he's thinking
you know somebody just blew up something
and then Islam and all these other
things so what do you think let's start
with you and we'll pass it around when
you see me Islam malign the way it is
you know on the on the news media and
you see all these negative things being
associated with Islam and people
associating Muslims with terrorism what
what goes to your mind what hum do learn
and basically I'm an individual that's
pretty void of media and because we know
the negative impact of media and also
that media the purpose of it is to get a
story right because they they're also a
business they have to function and they
have to have viewers in order to survive
so we have to remove ourselves from this
this media because it's only going to
cause us to react in a negative way
however but you know we forget about the
the day-to-day affairs and interactions
that we have with our neighbors just
taking our families you know to the park
some of my our families attend you know
various schools and public schools and
are very involved in associations like
the parent-teacher Association you know
so we have to you know remove this
negative image from the media by getting
involved in being seen in our
communities so that our neighbors and
our communities and laws can be aware of
the positive impact of the Muslims on
society being proactive the commute
exactly sure is that we're off to make a
good change no okay great next carry
that how do you feel now
when you hear this beautiful way of life
this way that when when the peacemakers
the people of peace have been made by
the media to look like the people of war
and you turn on fox news
you see radical islam what are your
feelings on that well I think more than
anything else we have to just learn how
to be Muslim I think that's something
that a lot of us has forgotten in our
day to day lives
it's just how to be normal human beings
that care about one another and it
doesn't have to be just to other Muslims
and I think that's something that we've
forgotten especially in the public space
so like brother Yousef said we need
authentic engagement with the public
sector he said we have parents that are
involved in the PTA how many parents in
here are involved with their PTA can I
get a show of hands so very few and so
PTAs and again any statistic that you
see about school performance school
measure whether it's in a private school
whether it's in a public school you'll
see that it only happens if you have an
active parent if you have parents that
are engaged in the process that care
about their children's upbringing and
many of you that have chosen even
Islamic or private school you yeah and
there's a select group of parents that
get involved there in private school at
the end of the day the child needs to
have parents that care but beyond that
in the public sector we need we need
community members to show up there's a
lot of issues that impact not only your
kids even if you don't have like I said
my child does not attend the public
schools but I'm still part of the Board
of Education does that disqualify me
from serving no because I have a vested
interest in the success of our community
that our community will not thrive
unless we have Concerned actors in the
community wanting to give back
wanting to bring positive change for all
community members because you know if if
we all don't get involved then as far as
your neighbor goes as far as your
neighborhood goes and the success of
that neighborhood it will all it will be
very limited if we all don't come
together and say ok we have to lift each
other up together and it doesn't matter
about race or creed it really makes no
difference and then since the the title
of the topic is enje Dawa I mean part of
that is actually getting involved right
wanting to benefit your neighbor wanting
to benefit your community so you know to
answer your question is that their
stereotypes of course does the media
portray us in a certain way obviously it
does there's a certain portrayal however
if you and I just be ourselves and act
according to what our faith tradition
says in the manner that we should
conduct ourselves people will see it I
mean even myself naturally I have all of
my colleagues I'm the only Muslim on the
board and there isn't a large Muslim
population where I live but what we work
on our issues that are common to all of
us and we work to successfully implement
programs and ideas and initiatives that
are going to benefit all the students
and if that's not part of my faith and I
don't know what is I mean we would like
to think that the media and and all
these you know things that our students
are exposed to and society is exposed to
doesn't have an impact but unfortunately
you got it you got to believe that
somewhere in the back of their head the
kids are thinking about it you know
because this is what they see that's all
they know from the standpoint of being a
Muslim mind I think that you know we
really have
do those as an ambassador we are an
ambassador of Islam and as was said here
I mean in a public school setting you
are probably the only Muslim adult that
these students know so I mean it's just
like getting involved in all these
things for Reta slam stands for an Islam
a Muslim should be viewed as a
value-added you know positive
contributor to society and really giving
back to the community to the best of
their ability and you know giving
excellence in everything they do
which we should strive for excellence
and strive to be and remember I always
keep that in the back of our heads that
we are an ambassador to Islam and we
shouldn't shy away from it you know we
should be proud of Islamic identity and
you know the things that we see that we
can make a positive impact for example I
mean as I said I'm a coach many times
you know I there stood there players who
maybe aren't fit to be on a team but you
know you get them on the team because
you get them off the streets and you
know that you can be a Madine in packets
you can do something positive that their
value they know and then it was
attributed to you you know that you know
you made a difference in my life and
also for students to feel that you know
and and know that you know you are a
Muslim I think it's it's it's impactful
it's effective so from that standpoint I
think it's very important just recently
we had a project graduation you know
after graduation they have like a
Midnight Madness and the purpose of that
is to keep kids off the street they
could be doing so many other things on
during graduation night so I'm going to
be able to have that type of a venue
where you're keeping you know students
off the street and keeping them in an
environment that islamically you know is
is what we should be advocating for you
know and anything where you can get
involved in that is threatened is behind
in supports you know the bad programs or
anything else where you know you can
bring a positive aspect to humanity and
be a positive contributor shake
shaquille go ahead we'll finish it off
with you great I just add what was said
I think we as Muslims in America need to
speak more to knowledge we're soul of
our own sachet into our institutions we
need to come out and speak more we need
to engage a lot more and I believe we
should have a presence in the media we
should be engaged in the media we should
be on CNN we should be on Fox News you
know why is it when they call someone to
speak about the Muslim point of view and
number one it's not a Muslim and at
times when it is a Muslim it's a person
was struggling to speak English so we
need a cultural change like so if
someone says hey mom hey dad I want to
be a journalist
what kind of pushback do they get right
so if he doesn't want to be a doctor if
it doesn't want to be a lawyer the other
professions are not regarded as as
highly as deal as the the first two I
mentioned so I think we need to have a
cultural change we need to realize that
we need a lot more people in the media
we should train people to get into
journalism they should be in the media
we should have our presence regular
presence understand what the media how
the media works and have a regular
presence and engage the media we need
people on CNN
we need people on Fox News we need
someone to go on Fox News and take down
pata Reilly we need that so let's go on
we're gonna go ahead and set up because
we have four panelists I've never had
this many on the Dean show hum did it
last so let's try to keep the I want to
get as many questions as possible out to
you guys so the more question is the
more we can have answers that will
benefit the the people or the viewers
watching so try to keep them short and
sweet I'm going to start with you
started from here make it fair tell us
why is important you heard when I opened
up I said that when you leave this life
you don't take all that money you made
do you you take the money you don't take
the money do you know you don't all the
billions trillions you don't take that
with you absolutely not okay but you do
take your actions is that right correct
so I talked about and this is from the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him who
was sent as a mercy to the whole of
humanity that if anyone looks at his
life sincerely will see that he was
indeed a Messenger of God just like
Moses Jesus Abraham he was sent by God
so he told us that a righteous child is
one that supplicate for you and helps
you in the next slide is that true so
talk to us how do we make a decision
that our children don't get corrupted
and we lose them and they don't we don't
we don't have them supplicating for us
when we pass in this life so how do we
make this decision between these three
so I think the first thing is to
understand that when we have children
it's a gift from Allah Subhan Allah tada
it's a gift from Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
but the gift that we get comes with a
certain nature the problem hardness
apply some said Mammon allude and in
Laguna do Allah filter there is it a
single child that's born except that
it's born the state of fitrah in the
state of Islam so Allah has given us a
child that is Muslim it's a Muslim how
are we going to return this child after
we raise this child to Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala
we're going to send this child to an
educational experience that will turn
the child into an atheist turned the
child into someone that will disobey
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala that's our
responsibility number two the Hadees
that the brother quoted one of them saw
their hair to her level
that's something and that will help us
in the next life and we have a righteous
it's one of them solid not any child a
righteous child that makes door for this
individual and Torah in the Islamic trim
analogy has two meanings as do I miss
Ella and Dora better the world masala is
the door when you supplicates so if he
supplicates
for you you will get the benefit
and though I better is that if he does
act a worship you get the reward
so imagine he's making tahajud you're
you're great you get your grave you get
the reward for that he's fasting here at
the grave you get the reward for that he
just gave $100,000 in Southwark lock you
get the reward for that so every single
good deed that a child does you get the
reward for that how can someone miss out
on that opportunity tell us when you
send okay you're a teacher they're
correct so we want we know that
environment has a great impact on us
especially our children so when you go
through some of the I know in Chicago I
don't know about New Jersey I take that
it's the same when you go through
somebody's school you got metal
detectors you know you're greeted with a
lot of bullying by other kids you got
promiscuity you got all sorts of
corruption drugs you got some good but
you when you see that a lot of times you
know the the bad outweighs the good so
if somebody is thinking about sending
their children they don't know right
they came from overseas and the public
school is next door would you encourage
them to send them in this environment
that's a tough question it is a tough
question and absolutely it is a culture
shot right absolutely
culture shock Machado shot gang violence
sure and again that depends obviously on
whether you're in the inner city or in
suburban areas or wherever the schools
located and and generally based on your
locale that's that's you know the type
of school you'll be attending
but regardless irrespective of the fact
that mean you do see it you're exposed
to a lot of fit then you know a lot of
trials and tribulations as you said and
that it is a challenge it is challenging
but in reality it's basically you know a
a look into the real world I mean this
is the society around us I mean that's
what we are exposed to so from that
standpoint
I mean if we think that we can shelter
our children to be exposed I mean to not
be exposed to that type of those types
of challenges you can't do it I mean you
can try to limit it or mitigate it as
much as possible and try to you know
deal with some of the issues but you
know realistically speaking if we
shelter for too long what happens I mean
there has to be a balance what happens
is they get into some type of a I guess
you could say something of a shock you
know they're shocked when they go out
into the real world and they have to you
know interact and yes you are going to
see promiscuity and you're going to see
a vulgar talk and you will see you know
all types of things that yes inside are
going to make you feel uncomfortable but
in essence you can't escape it you can't
escape it I mean the majority of the
careers that you will get into that is
prevalent I mean will that'll be all
around you and you know I I think you
just have to establish the foundation
and really work on strengthening
yourself and supplementing you know you
really have to supplement the Islamic
aspect and really you know inculcate
that into your children homeschooling
you met you mentioned that you
homeschool your children one yeah don't
have them how's that going for you and
if somebody wanted to do homeschooling
where do they start how do they start
well I think there's several things so
you know when my daughter became of age
of going to school and we do have a
pre-k in my school and I was on the
Board of Education we chose not to send
her in and she last year my wife and I
we had a small disagreement about
potentially sending her to a private
school which I considered to be one of
the best Islamic schools in the state
noble Leadership Academy and it's a few
blocks from our home and my wife said
maybe let's try it out for a year and I
spoke with the principal and I said you
know
I think we're going to hold off on
enrolling her the principal was very
disappointed however a few months ago
i'm speaking with the principal and i
said what do you think about our
decision of not sending our daughter to
school two year to your school I know
you wanted her here in Noble Academy and
she said it's the best decision you ever
made and I said why do you say that she
said that whatever you're doing in the
home you're doing a phenomenal
phenomenal job your daughter the
principal of the school yes by not
sending her there and I'm not saying my
dad is you know a genius she's you know
she's a regular six year old child
however what I am trying to convey is
that for every family there's a
different reality there's a reality for
each and every one of you with how you
raise your child and everyone has an
option and otherwise some families don't
have that option you have some families
where both parents are working and they
have to send their kid to and they're
not of means and they might have to send
their children to a public school some
have means and don't want to send their
child to a public school so they send
them to an Islamic school even if it may
not be the best Islamic school service
with private school I know you don't
want to say private but in this context
we kind of understand that it's going to
be specifically an Islamic school so I
think we have different realities that
everyone has to sort of accept in terms
of homeschooling what I find most is
that there's a psychological barrier for
most parents that right when they hear
it they say well I don't have a college
degree or I don't know all the subjects
or it's just going to be too much and so
we have these psychological barriers as
to accepting that as a reasonable
alternative to either public school
and/or private school and I think once
you know what I would say is you have to
know your child you have to know
yourself you have to know the
relationship with your spouse and then
also the extended family members and
once you kind of understand those
relationships you should start asking
the questions what is the best most
viable all
option for my child specifically for my
child we just knew that public school
and private school
the current alternatives that were
available to us would be stifling her
growth we felt and we felt that with we
didn't want to stifle her progress her
imagination and everything else and we
wanted her to go out and explore the
world and that's what we're doing with
her letting her experience the world
rather than experience a classroom
well sure let's keep it going public
school or over my dead body and the the
issue of public school versus assignment
school in homeschooling it pretty much
is based on social interaction
I'm usually a student that that is home
school I'm there far removed from
society and then when they are exposed
to society then they are immature or
they are naive meaning that they never
experience these type of things was
never seen these type of things so they
when they do see these things and they
become vulnerable when it may fall into
these traps now when we talk about
public school of course there's you know
a lot of social interaction
intermingling between the gender
negative exposure right and you know
it's a lot of you know fitna or
challenges in homeschool however when we
talk about Islamic schools most people
right remove their children from this
negative exposure and they put them in
Islamic schools so that they can learn
some type of morals and manners and even
you know if it's Islamic private school
or even a Catholic private school even
non-muslims they will send their
children to Catholic schools or
Christian schools because of the the
moral factor and this is you know the
fine line that kind of you know that
we're dealing with here that America it
is you know is considered
you know anymore you know society
there's a lot of things that are going
on you know in the streets in public you
know facilities as well as you know you
know schools are so forth and so on so
now how do we balance this you know with
the means that we have because you know
public schools are free Islamic schools
are very expensive you know in
homeschooling you know they're you know
pretty much you know affordable so as
you know it's very hard to to kind of
balance you know between between the
three public school my daughter will
come they'll uh she's been you know in
private school this is the first year
I'm actually a part of a product of
public schools I went to public schools
all of my life I went to a school where
you know the girls were knocking out the
guys you know and you know the guys were
beating up families you know that's
that's how bad you know it was guys were
beating up families you know so they get
in the fight with each other and then
the family comes in the family fight you
know so you know it was it was very
rough you know but one thing that I did
was stay involved right I got involved I
was involved in several programs the
college-bound program where kind of put
me in the group of people that had their
minds they had you know their their
minds set for college I was involved in
sports I played three sports and also
you know other you know activities on
the weekend right so the purpose of
lower they were suddenly said that there
are two blessings that many people
neglect they don't take advantage of and
these two blessings is good health and
free time so a lot of times you know our
children are given too much free time
and because of this free time you know
they they hang out with the wrong crowds
you know they're on their own sites you
know on the Internet
but if we keep them active into
extracurricular activities doing allow
them to do you
all types of activities family
activities and events on the weekend do
not think that this will help out a
little bit you know inshallah in the
journey for education thank you very
much this awful Ohio made the critter
that has earth reward you let's keep it
going we know that this beautiful way of
life that was set from the beginning of
time with the first man Adam submission
to the will of God
Islam oh we're living is the organic way
everybody guys got a Whole Foods over
here
you know Whole Foods everybody's going
back to organic so the way of life that
we live is this pure organic good
wholesome life that we raise our
children not to order profanity to
recognize to be God conscious to be
morally sound have the best characters
we're respecting those who are not yet
Muslims Muslims all of humanity to be
the best that they can be so how does
someone who's not in a predicament that
they don't have the money to send them
to a private school for example what
should they do
and they know they've heard from a
famous Christian who accepted he was a
Christian use of Estes from Texas he
accepted Islam and he grew up in this
environmental it he looked at me like
huh he said no no brother you don't
understand maybe it's my English I'm
saying I put my son in American public
school I said your English is fine how
is your Arabic why don't you put him in
the hammam because at least when you
take him out you can wash it off it's
strong but it still had an impact on me
I still remember that so now they heard
this they don't want to they don't know
where to begin with home school does a
place like your private school have a
backing word now you financial aid to
get it what do they do share I think
there a couple of issues one is I think
with with education we first need to
it's a problem every Muslim parent
thinks about it and we need to come up
with a solution but unfortunately almost
every family is fighting this battle by
themselves and that has to change as
Muslims we need to come up with a
solution that will be a solution to the
masses that will be a universal solution
now I also went to public schools all
right and I'm a product of public school
but one of the things that I'm sure we
did all of us here there's well but one
of the things we need to remember is
that when we went to public schools it's
not as how public schools are today with
their cell phones Facebook communication
is so easy which opens up the routes and
avenues for promiscuity it's different
it's a whole different ballgame they
never taught homosexuality in my any of
my schools when I was in public school
in elementary junior high or high school
right things are different today
so the dangers of of our children losing
their Deen is very high number one
number two with what my respected
brother said I'm going to have to differ
a little bit where he said that private
schools are expensive I disagree I
believe our private schools are very
very cheap and they need to charge more
and the reason for that is if you look
throughout the United States of America
the average Jewish school charges
fifteen thousand dollars a year that's
the average they're actually private
school that charge forty two hundred
thousand dollars a year the average
Jewish Bulls charge is fifteen thousand
dollars a year the average Catholic
school charges five thousand dollars a
year well guess we don't have to you
know reinvent the wheel we don't have to
become a statistic the statistics are
there look at the Catholic schools
they're all shutting down it's not going
to work five thousand dollars a year a
private school they're charging six
thousand dollars a year you talking
about two hundred dollars a month it's
not gonna
you end up getting under qualified
teachers you end up not having proper
resources in the classroom the parents
get frustrated my children are not
learning they're better off in the
public school system we put them between
a rock and a hard place to choose
between public school where they learn
some academics but risk losing their
dean and learn a lot of immoralities or
risk risk prism in private schools where
is not funded properly and they're not
going to get strong academics they will
never get into Columbia they will not
get into Harvard they will not get into
Yale it's a problem so to stop this
problem we need to look at the Jewish
schools their financial model they
charge $15,000 a year I am saying that
there shouldn't be any school run by
Muslims and it's a longer school any
school run by Muslims there shouldn't be
any school as run by Muslims that's run
by a Muslim the New York New Jersey area
that should charge less than ten
thousand dollars a year because with my
financial analysis it's almost
impossible to run a proper school with
the proper resources with certified
teachers that with less than $10,000 a
year well then the ideas are well then
it's only for the rich well it's not
we're going to have to run this way to
get critical mass the problem is we sent
them to to $203 months of school they
get this in education which is not great
they're not qualified to go to better
colleges they end up with low-paying
jobs and now they do the exact same
thing to their children
send them to the same school system an
hour and they graduate they end up in
community colleges why is it that when
we go to community colleges you see a
lot of Muslims
you've got Ivy League universities you
can barely find Muslims there that this
cycle has to be broken it has to change
and there will be pain in the beginning
but we have to sacrifice we need to call
on our entrepreneurs we need to call on
our businessmen to fund education
Harvard and Yale and Columbia they
charge high tuition but yet they still
get funding in the millions of dollars
because no matter how much money you
throw at education it's not enough so if
the Jewish people as a community can pay
fifteen thousand dollars a year and get
their children we see the result and get
high-paying jobs again
- good college why can't we a Jewish
family was asked how do you pay $15,000
a year the answer was simple
we don't go on vacations anymore it's it
I don't need a Mercedes I don't have to
go to long vacations the wife can get a
part-time job
there's today if you have a laptop and
an internet connection you can make
money if you can't there's something
wrong you get a laptop the wife can work
from home you can make some money add
extra income a couple of hundred dollars
a month $1,000 a month can help pay the
tuition so I think we need to change the
way we think free is expensive discounts
is the first thing we ask for that has
to change we should say how we should
say that how much more can we give to
education and until unless this doesn't
change we're gonna continue to suffer
now the other side is these private
schools that results the results because
the resources not there the hems of that
wellspring Elementary we've changed that
there are zero discounts zero discounts
anybody ask for discount we say no and
we have a waiting list of people trying
to get into the school this is at wall
spring Elementary this is only our
second year and but in this second year
we performed our children perform better
than ninety one percent of America so
it's possible if we create a proper
financial model we have a unique
education model that's different from
private schools other private schools
and public schools home schooling like
the brother said every family has a
different reality there are many
challenges to home-school not every
parent can be with their child all day
and then the dad has to come home and
the mom says all right you take the kids
I'm done kids all day and then the dad
after a day's work it's got to come and
take it
I commend any any any fan that's doing
homeschooling it's great but there are
challenges and it's important that in
today's day and time there's so much new
information coming out it's faster than
it was before and it's it's very
difficult for a mom to be an expert in
science to be an expert in math
to be an expert in literacy and then
keep up with the latest research and
every single subject you're going to
compromise education with your children
and then sitting in a classroom you're
missing the social interactions yes we
can have homeschooling Network take them
out and stuff but that's a lot of work
but what you're also missing is the
experience in the classroom yes I know
the answer is correct but another
student asks a question that I never
thought of I never thought of that
question and that question is
interesting and it allows us to to go
deeper in the subject in the classroom
right how many moms are trained in
developing higher-order thinking skills
for their children it's not just
teaching what two plus two equals
homeschooling how many parents are
trained in properly assessing their
child when I train my teachers I tell
them just because the child got the
right answer doesn't mean it's a proper
it's a good assessment you have to ask
how and why I could be a child I looked
at two plus two times two I said the
answer is four because I added the two
numbers I have multiply the two numbers
so not getting at the so getting at the
right answer doesn't necessarily mean
you understand it so the assessment I
know a family that is homeschooling the
they're in middle school they get their
courses online these kids they got their
parents log in they log in with their
parents ID they get the answers to the
exam they punch them in and the parent
thinks my children doing great okay so I
think there are a lot of challenges with
homeschooling it's not a solution that's
Universal it can work for some families
but we as a Muslim community as our
history showed us we always came up with
solutions drawing pictures was Haram we
didn't say art was Haram we came up with
the geometric art we came up with
beautiful art so when they're we come up
with challenge we need to come up with a
solution that doesn't solve a few
family's problems but it has to solve
the problem all the Muslims in America
and that's what we're doing at
Wellspring Elementary okay so let's
agree now we're gonna we're gonna change
the the whole topic we're gonna we're
gonna promote or we're gonna want to
agree that we want to send our children
to create a conscious schools how's that
character development schools right so
how do we avoid the fitna academies
sorry I put you on the spot how do you
avoid let me let me make it let me make
it easier because some some parents are
naive right
they then grow up here and they don't
know the culture really so they might
just go from from work home must JIT
they don't really know they don't really
watch much TV so they don't know really
what's that there's there's they're not
just learning you know French and I'm
not talking about you know the French
language you know they're learning you
know a whole new language that when they
go to the public schools you know a
whole new behavior the whole culture is
being invent Darwinism is that right
that's being promoted you know all sort
of things that conflict with a person
who's trying to live a good morally
wholesome organic life a god-conscious
life right so what can someone expect if
they send their per their children to to
an environment that's promoting the
opposite where it's cool to be bad it's
cool to curse the teacher isn't it yeah
yeah it is like you said I mean it's
advocated and people look highly upon
you know students then their peers they
look highly upon those students that act
up it's not cool to get good grades in
the public school you know so I mean
those it's not cool to get good grades
but in the public schools when we had
continued yeah right absolutely
I mean you know you know the kid that's
acting up is the class clown he gets the
high-fives and everything else but you
know machala knew it really is a
challenge and we have to realize you
know as Muslims that as you don't that's
what you said before we like the fresh
flesh our children down the toilets you
know and that's really what you're doing
when you're putting them in that
situation and not befriending your child
you have to be there for your child you
have to connect with your child you have
to be able to communicate and know
what's going on you know it's not just
in
type of school whether it's Islamic
school or anything else you can't think
to yourself you know and just assume
that I'll drop off my kids and the
school take care of the upbringing of my
child
you know it's an aspect and when you
think about it it's the time that the
child spends not doing anything else
they did was in school so that that's an
important and it's a large chunk of time
for within the day and you know in
certain aspects it's it's almost
difficult to rectify you know these
immoral behaviors that they're learning
you know where we grew up and you know
you you need not to talk back to a
teacher you have respect and I always
said I said you know as a high school
teacher I think there should be a
requirement that we have a DAB enough
luck 101 you know any better to
mannerisms and we do it we go into you
know these types of things because if
the students don't come in with an
attitude that is you know receptive and
willing to accept what you have to teach
them it becomes more challenging for the
teacher but the teacher obviously has to
you know pick up different you know
ideas and strategies to be able to reach
a child in a day and age where we're
talking about you know all this
technology that they have now where a
kid is used to being distracted about
video games and this you know technology
and and and latest technology as a
teacher you have to be able to put on
you know the ability to you know engage
those children in a way give it you know
teaching them what they need in a way
that you know they like it you know and
and that's something that is you know
it's challenging and and how many times
have you been given to burden school
back back back one these to bring apples
to the teacher
what from apples to boats but you
absolutely I mean it happens you know
teachers have been cursed that you know
different things that you know different
behaviors that students demonstrate and
you know as a teacher one of things you
really just have to you have to you have
to demonstrate patience and exercise
patience in in dealing with you know a
new generation it's a new generation of
students that are you know as we said
you know the you know they have no
problem flipping the but you know what
the streets are the same way if you've
ever been to New Jersey and you should
driven the rage in New Jersey's is
unlike anywhere else and that's it's the
reality people people act that way go
ahead so I mean I'm hearing a lot of you
know it seems like we want to keep our
children in a bubble we want to isolate
them and I understand where that comes
from I understand where that sentiment
comes from but if we can I keep it real
can I talk you know about the reality
okay so then if we're gonna keep it real
like if you set your child or anyone
that has grown up in New Jersey in New
York and you didn't hear about from
whiskey drugs or what do you promiscuity
in our private Muslim run Islamic
schools whatever you wanna call it then
you really didn't grow up here because
they exist even in our private school
sorry to break that I know
you know well I don't think nothing but
it happens it happens he's right it
happens it's um not as much it happens
it happens and as long as as long as
they're engaged with digital technology
as Humayun said right that there's this
they're flirting with each other in the
classroom it's all happening it's a
happening in real time even if there
might be in separate classrooms you know
the gender interaction doesn't happen
it's still happening in the hallways I'm
part of a child a charity called smile
for charity and we we did some self
image self lit self image self esteem
media literacy workshops specifically
with Muslim girls and one of you know I
was talking to someone out of this state
that works across the country doing
these types of workshops media literacy
in the self image self esteem workshops
specifically with Muslim girls
adolescent Muslim girls and I asked her
I was like question whether you're
dealing in these workshops a lot of it
is therapy I said you know like not even
I wouldn't say therapy but they're
unpacking and talking to what the issues
that they're facing in school out of
school I said who has more issues those
that are going to private schools
they're those that are going to public
schools they said by far the girls in
private school they said by far have
more issues and that was a very
interesting conversation because it
opened up my eyes to a whole new reality
that we're not like if you're going and
sending your child to a private school
for insulation they're still going to be
facing a slew of other issues that they
don't know they can't reconcile what
they see on TV the values that they
learn from their teacher then the values
that they teach they learn at home
they're not able to reconcile it they
just see all these different messages
coming hitting them
they don't know what to do they don't
know who they are and then next thing
you know they're in the university and
then everything goes out the window
so I preface the excuse me right from
the beginning when I was speaking that
on every every family has a different
reality every one has a different
situation but what the most important
thing is what you're teaching inside the
house the values that you have and that
fact that they have to be congruent
there has to be congruent between your
actions and your values and they even a
lot of times what's happening in the
schools is that there's just so many
different mixed signals mixed messages
that the child just doesn't know what to
do what their role in society is
supposed to be so I'm not saying that
you know you know again like insulation
might protect them from certain things
but it's not the end-all be-all it's not
the magic pill that's going to lead your
child to successful conclusion let's go
ahead you wanted to say something
quickly he's gonna go just keep these
short and sweet so we're almost out of
time let's engage a little bit more
everybody I mean I don't agree with
private schools that say don't send your
kids to public school send them to us
because we are holier than thou we don't
do that well spring Elementary that's
why we don't call ourselves Islamic
schools because we separate ourselves
where a lot of this the stigma and
stereotypes about Islamic source number
one that's that's a mistake number two
insulation is wrong do not shelter your
children do not try to insulate your
children that's a mistake
that's wrong we at wellspring elementary
want our children to win that when they
see evil to mention it in school now the
difference between the private schools
and public schools is if they see evil
no one's gonna correct it because it's
not a lot of the evils that we as
Muslims see as evil is not considered
are not considered evil at the public
schools so we welcome these ideas and
these thoughts that are wrong because
then we train them and teach them how to
deal with these evils so the problem is
not with a private school the problems
with the staff at the private school and
that's a whole separate discussion the
proper staffing at the private school
unfortunately a lot of our private
schools if you can speak English you get
hired right and that's a mistake and
that's a huge mistake if you're the wife
of the the person the board
you're a head teacher and that's a
mistake and these things have to stop
right so it's not the problem the
private school model it's a problem the
staffing I'll give you one example at
our school love Spri elementary what
he's mentioning about girls having
problems in our private school it's
correct it's a problem why because we've
created a fictitious atmosphere in our
schools as if it's Mecca or Medina
thousand years ago right well in our
school I was pretty elementary we have
staff that are not Muslim because we
live in America our children will be
dealing with non-muslims so they learn
how to deal with us and they learned
that there are other people who don't
worship allah subhanho wa taala
so what's the end result we have our
five-year-olds having discussion
discussions with our gym teacher she's
not a Muslim the five year old have a
discussion with her and he's giving her
dower to Islam why don't you come to
Islam wanted to be a Muslim why don't
you wear hijab so and so forth right so
they're getting this at a very early age
number two a lot of privates of a lot of
our private schools and I guarantee if
you check it out hey jab is part of the
uniform but she's not wearing hijabs
she's not allowed on the school guess
what a wellspring Elementary hey Jeff is
not partly uniform it's not part of
uniform hey job is more sacred and to
bring it down to a level and make it as
a uniform of a school and when you do
that a psychological problem
the psychological terapia that you're
giving that child is you put this on
when you go to school as soon as you
step out you take it off we don't tell
our girls to wear hijab we create the
love for Allah and the love of the
Prophet Muhammad's eyes on them and they
pick up the hijab and put it on
themselves I'll give you one example we
had a five year old girl who forgot her
hijab at home in kindergarten she came
to the doors of well of Wellspring she
refused to enter the school and we said
why but it knows because hey job is not
uniform she's I forgot my hijab at home
want to pass by the morning assembly
because boys will be there we said it's
okay for today you can pass by a
five-year-old girl no big deal just no I
don't want to pass by so I said you have
to come down we can't your parents you
have to come down so she took a school
bag she covered her face walk down pass
by all the boys and she was tearing and
went straight to her teacher to get an
extra hijab this girl when she grows up
evening laugh it's not gonna have that
messed up problem because she chose to
wear hijab she loves to wear hijab she
sees others and ask them why don't you
wear hijab so in our private
institutions we can't create that
fictitious fictitious environment we
can't shelter them from evil that's the
wrong method how they feelin young man
said Kenan ass yes I don't know sort of
ISIL I summon a shop welcome to I said
to who can hate welcome to I said oh
honey shop maja fat I knew trickery so
the people used to ask The Messenger of
Allah so let's learn about the good
I would asking about the evil fearing
that it would catch up with me so evil
don't shelter them from evil minimize
the evil the evil in private schools can
be dealt with because there's no the
peer pressure is much less their peer
pressure as the brother mentioned in
public schools you got to do the evil
although as you're not cool whereas in
private schools if you're set the right
environment and you mitigate and you
minimize the evil and you allow it to
exist and you deal with it and you train
them how to deal with it you're
preparing them for the real world we got
to get our let our brother reign in this
creator conscious academy are the not
yet Muslims because every human being
has the potential to submit to the
crater are they allowed Jews Christians
people from other religions are they
allowed to come open its open all open
for all and the effect we have this
anomalous ylim gym teacher her she comes
from 10:00 a.m. to 1:00 p.m. and she
leaves at 1:00 p.m. 1:15 the school
makes solo every day she stays longer
than her work hours come one question to
watch is I want to see this solo
when the kids say subhanAllah hamd
allahu ekber to make at the car after
salah i feel peace in my heart
and you know why she feels that it's
because when she was pulled out of a
domani sedan and allah said unless to
build up become am i not your lord she
said yes this is the spiritual DNA this
is the spiritual memory when she sees
Muslims mix Allah when she see Muslims
make of cow or McVicker that spiritual
memory is awakened so yes we need to
engage with non-muslims we need to speak
to them and we can't live being a
complete separate community that's not
gonna work you wanted to get in on this
yes
Smita actually my my major is its
business and I have a master's in
business administration and so I look at
these things from a business perspective
and one thing to the Muslims is that we
have to begin to work together and pull
our resources together and we have to
establish an Islamic Board of Education
and when we are able to establish an
Islamic board education it allows us to
do many things and number two is that it
allows us to look for other type of
financial resources amongst the at our
communities and we forget that we are
sometimes we that we are citizens of
this particular country and that we pay
taxes and there are a lot of resources
out there for us
such as grants but as well as vouchers
financial bouncers for schools and we
have to begin to apply pressure on the
states or particularly the state of New
Jersey that there are other states that
allow their parents to educate their
children how they please and they
provide them with
vultures right so that they can
subsidize for their education so until
we you know put pressure on the state of
New Jersey then we will always have a
lack of resources and mainly financial
resources and our slamming schools and
they'll be very difficult for us so
events and the last thing is that we
have to raise the bar
we know that the educational system here
in America it is deteriorating and a lot
of times if we are not on the standards
of our states or the American
educational system that we suffer that
we are deprived and in fact when we look
at Islam and go back to the golden ages
of Islam that Islam right we control the
science we developed the sciences of
science and the math and and medicine
and so forth and so on
and that as Islamic schools technically
we are we are private schools with
Islamic departments and we have to go
from Islamic schools with our private
schools within cymet departments to
full-time Islamic schools
meaning that all of the academic studies
right Islam have to be incorporated
within these subjects that if I am a
health the history teacher then and we
talk about world history and we talked
about the great empires like Mesopotamia
and Egypt and so forth or so on and I
don't inform that the children that
Ibrahim Alisa mom was born in
Mesopotamia you know that if we look at
world history that all of the the
countries that we deal with the world
history or is the Middle East today and
these teachers right we never connect
Islam right to these academic subjects
and we Department lies Islam and we put
it in the whole different
category right and at the same time that
we have to understand that we cannot as
parents we we cannot necessarily push
our our kids to to memorize the Koran or
to memorize the entire book Harding
right we have to be able to assess their
skills in their talents right and be
able to develop them you know on the
base of their talents right and this is
very important because a lot of times
the either the the parents they send
their kids to Islamic schools number one
to push them to memorize Quran with
where they may not have the ability to
do so or is a rehabilitation meaning
that they spend so caught up in public
schools that they put them in in the
Islamic schools you know for their last
few years of high school and think that
the Islamic school is going to fix them
so there's things that we have to do as
a community and it has to be something
that is practical right and this
practical thing that we have to do is
the example is a summer you know Board
of Education
until then then we still will be have
like a lack of financial resources and
we will still try to meet the standards
you know of American education where
Islamic education it is an includes
religious studies as well as academic
studies right and we have to enhance
that right and if we are able to do this
if we are able to change the standards
where we're graduating students from
high school in the tenth grade or these
students are actually taking college
classes you know one day in the tenth
grade and they're gaining two years of
credits you know while they are still in
high school we this is the area that we
have to
because the education here in America
has has to change and we are the ones
that can change it
because Islam is the the religion of
Allah and Allah Ta'ala and we have to
make sure that we apply in all of our
lives and not just isolated to Islamic
studies Arabic and Quran not just
isolated to the message but we have to
go beyond that and show not to either
Chocula hide I'd like to thank all of my
guests thank you and the creator of the
heavens on earth rewards you
we started with peace we end with peace
almost out of time we're gonna go ahead
thank you again and hopefully inshallah
God willing we'll meet again and thank
you for tuning into the Deen show and
remember like our guests said it starts
at home it starts at home you teach your
children to be God conscious to love
their creator to have a consciousness of
their creator to know the purpose of
life from a young age connect them with
their Lord their maker and put trust in
him call upon him and be assured that
when you trust in your Creator
you work to please your Creator and you
do all the wonderful things as he's told
us to do it's lost a mission to the will
of God that things will be okay
inshallah God willing never fall into
despair do the right thing all the time
and we'll see you next time give us a
call if you like what we had to say and
you want to pick up the verbatim Word of
God 1 800 662 m we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you